in chapter 5 of 1p Zorro officially
accepted Luffy's offer to join the crew
and that only two years this partnership
would lead him to become two of the
strongest fighters in the entire world
but what if Zoro rejected Luffy's offer
and never joined the straw hat crew how
far would Luffy get on his journey and
before we jump into the changes this
would make to the story let's actually
take a quick look at the moment that
inspired this whole video when Luffy
first invited Zorro to join the crew now
at this point Zoro was tied to a post
for saving this little girl here from
these bad doggos now Luffy then invited
him to become the very first crew member
and you might not remember it but Zorro
initially refused however then when
Luffy recovered his swords and then
freed the green moss head from his ropes
he finally agreed to join the crew but
obviously for this video Let's assume
that Zorro actually rejects Luffy a
second time slapping away his invitation
like Eight dollar request from a creepy
stranger and if this were the case Luffy
would leave Zorro tied up which would
lead to him actually being executed by
the Marines but honestly another much
more likely scenario here is that Luffy
would of course still said Zorro 3
because he does know deep down that
Zorro is a good guy and so after
defeating the Marines Zoro would thank
Luffy but then simply walk away and
pursue his dream of becoming the world's
strongest swordsman on his own and this
will have massive consequences in almost
every part of the story because as we
will see throughout this video whenever
Luffy is on his own he usually finds a
way to almost gets him killed I mean wow
how's this guy even gonna become king of
the Pirates anyways but now without
sorrow let's start with guano country
wait what why are we starting so late in
the story you ask since the point of
this video is to see how far the straw
hats would get without Zorro it made
sense for me to start at the end and
work our way backwards so we'll be
examining each of zoro's important
moments in the story and then seeing how
things would be different without him
because spoiler alert the straw hats
wouldn't have made it that far and so
because we're going in reverse order
there won't be any major storyline
changes like in some other what-if
scenario so before we look at all of
zoro's legendaries bad later on let's
start early on in the arc because during
wano he did have some minor fights like
against this straw man and in a battle
to stop this former Diamond's execution
but in each of these conflicts there
were other straw heads present who could
easily perform the very same role here
and not even counting the battles his
history as a descendant of wano never
really ended up playing a role in the
actual story so even if he wasn't here
during the arc you could have said that
the straws would just be as motivated to
fight kaido which now of course takes us
to the climatic Battle of onigashima and
here Zorro was a major participant in
the rooftop battle against big mom and
kaido and his presence was definitely
felt here he definitely got in on a few
massive attacks and blocked one of the
strongest attacks we have seen in the
entire story so far but ultimately this
battle was never really decided either
way so did he really make that big of a
difference however afterwards we have of
course his truly epic battle against
kaido's right-hand man and the strongest
member of the Beast Pirates King and
while this was an incredibly High battle
there are other characters nearby who
probably could have fought King as well
in the worst case in particular Mark of
the Phoenix was not doing much at all
during this fight so he could have been
a good match to fight the flying
dinosaur likewise Luffy could have
handled King no problem once he had been
done with kaido I think and so even
though zoro's fight was incredibly epic
and we saw him awaken his conquerors
hockey as disappointing as it may sound
the straw hats ultimately probably would
have been fine in wano even without
Zorro but I can promise you that this
will not be the case for many of the
arcs later on in the story or I guess
earlier on in the story however since
Zara wasn't in whole King Island at all
we'll just move on ahead to though and
on the back of this giant elephant
Zorro's fighting abilities weren't
really need it again however he did
demonstrate one of his super important
roles on the crew which is his
leadership because when Sanji left to
take care of his family problems Zorro
told the rest of recruit that Sanji
better well apologized for his actions
he left the crew at a super important
time in the story plus he was going to
stir up trouble with a second Emperor
and zoro's role here is important
because he is the only one who will
really step up and demand respect for
the crew and their captain and while
this tense moment didn't result in any
major conflict yet at least it was a
great reminder for Luffy about the honor
and respect needed on the crew however
even if Zorro wasn't here to give that
reminder I do not think that it would
have changed Luffy's actions much in
whole cake Island anyways however that
is definitely not the case for another
important moment coming up in the crew
later on you might know what I'm talking
about but three arcs down and the straw
hats would have been just fine in each
one so far interesting maybe one day if
zoro's sense of direction really got him
lost might actually just be fine however
this brings us all the way to dressrosa
where Zorro fought and defeated this
giant Stoneman however this is another
enemy who isn't really all that powerful
I mean how could he be with a voice
[Music]
ah so someone like La Sabo or even Luffy
again could have probably defeated Pika
almost instantly and just fine if there
had been need for it and so moving back
even further Zoro does have this very
nice moment in Punk Hazard where he
yells at Luffy that he should finally
take things seriously after he almost
dies at the hands of this gas man he
reminds Luffy that they are now in the
most dangerous part of the world and of
course Luffy laughs it off so maybe it
wouldn't matter even if Zoro was here to
remind his captain not to mess around
too much zaro also defeated this
Snowbird lady but someone else could
have easily taken her out as well ever
being honest which is now already
bringing us all the way back to the time
scale so as you can see zaro's influence
in the Post Time skip Arc so far was
actually not as important as you might
have previously thought and that's
because even though Zoro has a fight in
basically every Arc after the time skip
the crew is not as challenged like they
were pre-time skip at least not yet that
is already changing as we know plus on
top of that that everyone else in the
crew is now fairly strong as well so
Zoro isn't the only one that's able to
fight strong Fighters now but things
very different the further back we go in
the story now of course Zorro doesn't
play any role in the events leading up
to marineford because the straw hats
aren't here and even though the straw
hats were defeated on Saba ODI zaros
absent probably wouldn't have really had
any major effect on the outcome anyways
and so where it's starting to get really
interesting is when we travel back and
discuss the nightmare Island Thriller
bark where Zorro has his most badass
moment in the entire story and it's not
only zoro's most badass moment it's
probably the most badass one in his very
first fight of the rxr defeats his
ancestor which is this zombie swordsman
but I definitely think that nightmare
Luffy could have probably also defeated
the samurai however the even greater
conflict came at the end of the arc when
Zorro stood up to the warlord Kuma to
save Luffy and in exchange for Luffy's
life Zorro agreed to take on all of his
Captain's pain from the previous battle
this of course resulted in the world
famous nothing happened scene which is
personally my favorite in the entire
story however with Zara not in the crew
it would have probably Fallen to Sanji
to take on his Captain's pain I mean
Sanji actually wanted to do this anyways
but Zorro knocked him aside so in this
case Sanji takes on all of the pain and
we seriously have to ask if he would
have been able to survive this just like
Zorro did and I mean I love Sanji as
much as the next man and so please don't
hate me if you're more Sanji than Zorro
but I honestly do think that the answer
would likely be no Zorro is shown all
throughout the story to have crazy
endurance and the ability to fight
through pain and so even though we've
recently learned more about sanji's
incredible body it was not awakened at
that point in the story so I don't think
that he would have been able to survive
this crazy amount of damage and so
apology Sanji but it does look like you
probably needed your moss-headed friend
after all but since we're now getting to
the points in the story where Zorro is
absolutely necessary I do want to add
one major disclaimer because even though
there will be a bunch of points where
Luffy would fail without Zorro we can
usually find some sort of reasons for
the straw hats to be able to continue
for example in this situation with Kuma
it is possible that the warlord takes
Mercy on them because he is friends with
Luffy's father after all while we can
usually find some sort of excuse like
that there are gonna be some arcs that
are just impossible to move on from
without Zorro again very early on in the
story which now brings us to the
government's judicial Islands in his
Lobby and during this Arc we see one of
the three major characteristics that
Zorro actually brings to the crew two of
these we will be discussing in upcoming
arcs very soon but the first
characteristic that I want to focus on
is that he's just a straight out badass
fighter at this point in the story he
Luffy and Sanji are the only three
strong ones who can really fight in the
crew no offense to Nami and Robin quite
yet and Chopper does lose his mind when
he goes berserk at this point so Zorro's
absence here is a major problem when
Luffy is somehow distracted or taken out
here because there is just no one left
to protect the other and honestly if you
look back this situation happens in
basically every single Arc but maybe
that just means that Luffy would take
things more seriously so he doesn't put
the rest of the crew in danger
but then again kind of doubt it so let's
keep this in mind as we shift back to
zoro's fight against this sword wielding
giraffe now Zoro eventually wins this
battle and claims the key number five
which is the exact key needed to free
Robin from her handcuff so without Zorro
winning this fight Robin would have been
trapped for good however I do think that
someone else like Luffy or Sanji could
possibly have defeated the giraffeman as
well so in the end Robin might still
somehow Go free even without Zorro if he
really wanted to however I think we also
have to acknowledge that the crew also
probably wouldn't have made it that far
without sanji's fantastic food who who
knows might well be the most famous
Japanese cook worldwide if you also want
to try some delicious Japanese food you
already know what is coming next boxu is
this Channel's most loyal and most tasty
sponsor which is this awesome monthly
snack box full of Japan's best snacks
and tea pairings and every box who is
carefully put together with authentic
traits from family businesses and it
hasn't disappointed me even a single
time so far and this month Voxer is
celebrating their seventh birthday with
this fantastic tanjobi box including
some of my personal highlights so far
like this hojicha crunch chocolate or
these dried Nikon slices
um if you still haven't treated yourself
to this for whatever reason and want to
support the channel at the same time you
can use the link in the description
below and use my code Ohara to get 15 of
your first box of order and the straw
hats might well need one of these two to
calm their nerves because things are
starting to really get out of hand
without Zorro however moving back to
water 7 we get another critical example
of how without zoro's presence as The
Unofficial Vice Captain the crew would
surely been falling apart so you will
remember that the crew reached water 7
in need of a new ship this of course
Sparks the fierce duel between usop and
Luffy which results in usob leaving the
crew for a while and this is an
incredibly important moment for the
crew's long-term future that's because
if Luffy gave into usab's demands it
would have shown the crew that Luffy is
not a strong leader in Captain and is
not really worthy of their loyalty
however in another really famous scene
in chapter 333 Zorro will not let Luffy
take the easy route and he reminds Luffy
that making these difficult choices are
gonna be the burden of being the captain
and so without Zorro In This Moment
Luffy may very well have chosen to keep
usup's friendship rather than do what
was best for the crew and if Luffy let
usop rejoin the crew right away or
agreed to keep using their ship it would
probably have had disastrous
consequences later on in the story for
example if they did keep using the merry
it could have sunk in the middle of the
ocean without anywhere to escape to or
if Luffy didn't earn the respect of the
crew in this scene they may not always
listen to his orders later on and so
this lack of respect and Leadership
could eventually lead to a tragic
breakup during some future conflict and
so here we have our first true example
of zoro's importance to the overall
stability of the crew because I really
don't think that anyone else on the crew
is as serious and as devoted to respect
to have the very same level of impact as
Vice Captain I mean Sanji is kind of
wishy-washy usop has his moments but is
too weak physically and Nami would
rather avoid these kinds of serious
issues within the crew and besides his
fighting and his leadership qualities
there is an even more important third
characteristic that no one else on the
crew possesses because out of all the
straw hats Zorro is the one most
single-mindedly focused on his goal to
become the world's greatest swordsman
and out of all other straw hats it is
probably the pretty much easiest goal to
understand Probably sounds a little bit
something like this in zoro's Minds step
one get stronger step two defeat enemies
step three question mark four profits
simple right but Zoro is also the only
one that we consistently see training to
actually reach his goals he's frequently
lifting Ultra heavy weights or
practicing his sword skills and I do
like to think that this has some effect
on the crew as well and so we do have to
wonder if losing Zorro would make the
crew less dedicated towards their own
goals I think Luffy at least would of
course still want to become pirate king
but as you'll see in just a moment zaro
was truly irreplaceable in the early
parts of the story story also if Zara's
not there to butt heads with Sanji then
the cook's pervertedness might have
reached even more ridiculous Heights and
who knows Nami could even kill Sanji
herself if he peeps in on her bath once
so many times but now on to Sky Pia
where zaro plays a key role in the
outcome of the arc his major action here
was when he defeated the winged puppy
love and while there was no one else
around to really take this guy out I
can't imagine Luffy defeating him pretty
easily once he got out of the snake and
after this one none of the surviving
characters can actually defeat the
lightning god and also Zorro basically
takes a nap until he helps cut down the
giant beanstalk as a result without
Zorro it is possible that the Beanstalk
never gets cut down which means that
Luffy would have never reached NL in
time to deliver the final blow but I do
think that between this Warrior's
dedication and nami's cleverness they
would have probably been able to find
some way to get Luffy to Eno but again
maybe not which now brings us to
Alabaster and the juicy bits of this
video now zoro's main role in this Arc
is to take take down the warlord
crocodile's right-hand man Mr one and
originally this was a huge moment of
growth for Zorro as he finally learned
how to cut steel kind of crazy actually
that he couldn't even do that up until
that point in the story because we've
really gotten used to it however with
Zorro out of the picture someone else
will need to step up to this insane
blade man from tearing through the crew
certainly I think Luffy could eventually
figure out a way to beat Mr one even
though Luffy and sharp things don't
really get along that well especially at
that point in the story but Luffy
already had his hands full with
crocodiles so someone else would have
needed to take out Mr one or at least
distract Croc man or Mom while Luffy
takes out Mr blades and I do think that
their best chance is a combination of
Sanji and Nami where Sanji could keep Mr
one busy while Nami figures out how to
strike him with lightning but honestly
it sounds kind of questionable and I do
think this is a serious candidate for a
place where the straw hats might fail
without Zorro but that's not the only
critical role that Zoro plays here he's
also part of the team that helps VV
reach the bomb and so without Zorro
there to fling Chopper and Vivi into the
sky they would have had to come up with
another plan to reach the top I mean
perhaps Usopp could quickly make some
sort of giant slingshot or another
option is that the Marine Captain smoker
could help by using his smoke logia
powers to get them up there to the bomb
but again with no Zorro there things
look very dark and you might fairly
enough be asking why would smoker out of
all people be willing to help them here
but I don't think that a marine Captain
would stand just around if he knew that
Millions would be able to die from a
giant bomb plus these are desperate
times without our favorite Swordsmen so
we've gotta get a little bit creative
here to get the straw hats past this
hurdle and so after Luffy defeats
crocodile the striats get their next
major bounties and without Zorro to take
much of the credit the rest of the
starts probably will get a pretty decent
bump in each of their bounties which is
great news for Sanji usop and maybe even
Chopper finally gets some of the respect
that he deserves here but Nami is
certainly not pleased with with this
turn of events so as punishment she
demands that you will subscribe to the
channel for more one piece content just
like this but now let's jump out of the
desert and continue moving backwards
even more into even more critical
territory here certainly the straw hats
would be just fine in little garden and
drum Island since Zorro basically just
got stuck in wax and then decided to
have a little winter time workout in the
snow however that brings us to the booze
Lover's favorite island whiskey Peak
because here the straw hats were tricked
into passing out drunk and then the
entire Island tried to capture them to
earn their bouncy money however Zorro
was sober enough to fight all of them
off until Luffy and the others were
waking up and so while Zoro did do a lot
of work here none of these enemies were
super powerful so maybe Luffy and the
others would have eventually gotten free
no matter what but again maybe not might
be hard to believe but over 900 chapters
in reverse and we've only had one real
moment so far where zoro's absence could
have led to an eventual breakup and
failure of the crew and a few others
that required fairly Creative Solutions
for the crew to advance however no
absolute crushing defeats yet and so
next up is the East blue the weakest of
all the Seas and so it should be a walk
in the park for the straw hats right
right well let's just see how they can
survive our Long Park here the straw
hats will again be missing zarosphere's
loyalty to the crew because in chapter
71 Zorro confronts Nami in front of this
gang of fishmen and here Nami is still
pretending that she doesn't care about
the crew but zaro does not believe her
like at all in fact to prove that she
still belongs with the crew he throws
himself into the water now this forces
Nami to choose to let him drown or save
him herself now of course Nami does end
up saving him proving to both Zorro and
Nami that she very much cares about the
crew and Luffy and so without Zorro here
this entire Arc could play out
completely different Nami may not be as
convinced about her true feelings for
the straw hats or at least it may take
way longer for her to finally break down
and accept help but beyond the emotional
Stakes zaro also played a significant
role in the fights in arlong park
because even though he was still
severely injured from his early battles
with mihawk more on that very soon no
worries he fought off this sword
wielding octopus and even kept the
Fishman's Captain arlong busy when Luffy
was trapped on the water in other words
without Zorro someone else like Sanji
would have needed to step in to fight
arlong until Luffy was rescued and this
presents all types of major problems and
challenges since Sanji was the one who
ended up having to break the rock that
Luffy was trapped in so either someone
else would have to keep Ireland busy
sorry usop I guess or someone else would
have needed to free Luffy but I truly
don't know who else would have been
strong enough to do that here and so
once again this is our first clear
example where Luffy would have very
easily died if Zoro would have never
joined and so it's really a stretch of
the imagination to say that Sanji does
fight of arlong long enough for Luffy to
be freed by us up with that heroically
blast the rock of Luffy's legs with a
cannon and so with Luffy free he can
then defeat arlong and Rescue nami's
Village for good but that's a real big
stretch here so maybe another narrow
Escape but the same cannot be said of
baratier where there is literally
nothing that the straw hats can do on
their own to survive but let's not get
ahead of ourselves here because first it
is possible that they will never find
sanji's floating restaurant at all
because in chapter 42 the straw Hat's
new ship is attacked by everyone's
favorite Bounty Hunter Johnny and yosaku
Luffy is ready to kick them off the ship
but then Zoro recognizes Johnny and they
quickly become friends and get
directions to the baratier however if
sorrow was not on board Luffy might have
just thrown them overboard and this
could lead to them never finding a
baratia so with no Zorro probably no
Sanji however let's say there are some
possibilities that could still lead them
to Sanji for example Luffy might still
want to recruit one of these bounty
hunting Bros since he still needs strong
Fighters or even if he doesn't they
could still hear about the barazier from
someone else on another Island so let's
just assume that they end up finding the
burratier somehow where they 100 will be
completely annihilated without Zoro here
after destroying part of the restaurant
Luffy is forced to work as a chore boy
to pay off the damage that is until this
pirate Commodore eventually shows up and
starts shooting up the place and Zorro's
role in this fight is basically zero
however when the world's strongest
swordsman mihawk makes his appearance
things completely change you see
originally Miha came to the baratier
intent on taking down this very same
pirate who was now attacking the
restaurant and after mihawk easily Cuts
their giant ship in half Zorro steps up
to challenge the Warlords and even
though they're always utterly defeated
here mihawk is so impressed by zoro's
Honor as a swordsman and his loyalty to
Luffy that he does decide to leave
everyone else alone and this scene
perfectly shows off something only Zorro
can bring to the crew he is fiercely
honorable while Luffy Nami and USA will
use every trick in the book to defeat an
enemy Zorro will face an opponent head
on in an honorable duel he's also
intensely loyal to the crew so much so
that he places Luffy's dreams and life
ahead of his own and it is these very
traits that so Inspire mihawk to let
everyone else live and so without Zoro
and the crew there is no telling what
mihawk might have been doing to the
straw hats would she'd still be
satisfied just taking this guy's head
maybe or what he probably not want to
continue to eliminate all of the other
Pirates at the restaurant and if mihawk
were to come after Luffy then our rubber
man has absolutely no chance whatsoever
against the world's strongest swordsman
at this point so the straw hats fade
would very entirely be out of their
hands again stretching things really far
let's maybe say that mihawk is feeling
generous or maybe the head chef zeph
convinces him to spare Luffy because he
still needs to work off his depth or
maybe just be honest this introvert
might just want to return to his Dark
Castle but without Zorro this would
definitely be a time that the straw hats
could have been easily wiped out and
that is even more true in the arc before
this one syrup Village so let's back up
to chapter 23 with Luffy zaro and Nami
sailing to usop's home Island and now
that Nami is steering the ship the risk
of Death At Sea is basically zero so the
trio travels to sort of village where
they meet the boy who cried wolf USA and
zoro's role in this Arc is minimal until
the final battle where he fights these
felon brothers and at this point in the
fight Luffy was hypnotized and asleep so
unless Nami woke him up they would all
have been in serious trouble so it is
entirely possible that the crew is taken
out completely because Luffy was tricked
into a situation where he cannot help
himself or the crew wow I mean these
guys really need Zorro but of course we
could imagine that somehow they make it
out alive again maybe Luffy just never
gets put to sleep or that Nami is able
to wake him up earlier maybe Usopp
shoots him with some smelling salts
speaking of which wow these things are
powerful but with this one I really
don't think that they would have been
able to survive at all I mean without
Zorro Luffy is literally the only strong
fighter so once again the straw hat
Journey here is at its end without Zorro
but we can even take it another step
back to Orange town and see how Luffy
would do in the very first Arc without
Zoro it's in this small village that
Luffy first meets Nami and zenzaro isn't
even on the island yet Luffy is still
captured by buggy the clown so Luffy is
locked in a cage and he is about to be
blasted by buggy special cannonballs
however in chapter 11 he is saved when
Zoro fights of buggy and then flips the
cannon away from Luffy Zoro then carries
Luffy's cage away from buggy and into
the town and so with nozaro there Luffy
is completely helpless Nami already
tried to save him but she was no match
against Buggy's crew so unless Luffy was
able to somehow chew his way out of this
cage his pirate Adventure is over after
just a single Island without Zorro so uh
now you know why we did it first but
while Luffy's Journey with alzaro is
basically over after just a single
Island that means that the other straw
hats never get to pursue their dreams as
part of the crew and this brings us to
an even more interesting question
because what would have happened to
everyone else in the story including
Zorro if Luffy had never been born at
all and if you want to watch that video
you can do so right here thanks for
watching and I see you in the next one